ça veut dire que c'est un bon signe qui
la prend pas la voie quand on amène ou
ils vont nous exproprier et puis on sait
pas quoi s'attendre encore si la voix de
contournement devient une réalité le
terrain de trois hectares de Raymond
Savoie sera scindé en deux et sa maison
de centenaire devra être déménagé ils
ont enfin 800 000 ça n'a aucun sens
depuis plusieurs années lui et sa
conjoint sont très préoccupés par la
situation qu'on a pas de vie
plus comme 22 des 43 opposants au tracé
ils ont demandé à Maître Frédéric Paris
de les représenter qui va avoir beaucoup
de travail à faire on est à des années
lumières de 100 ans dans certains
dossiers ça a pas d'allure il faut que
la science mène la décision et pas une
date du 10e anniversaire je pense c'est
clair avec la lettre de l'OTC l'Office
des transports du Canada et on dit
écoute il y a des inquiétudes assez
importantes le mairesse de l'acte
migrants et David Ottawa doit aller de
l'avant selon elle ça fait un an que
négociation se font degré agréé il y a
de l'opposition certes mais ce n'est pas
la majorité des gens qui sont contre le
projet on doit pas se positionner pour
ou contre parce qu'ultimement ce n'est
pas un projet où ce n'est pas la
popularité c'est un enjeu de sécurité
non un jeu de popularité alors nous sur
la raison de base comme quoi on doit
minimiser les risques il faut sortir ce
train-là du centre-ville et c'est ce
qu'on va faire l'espoir s'amenuise pour
les opposants dans sa déclaration
Ottawa dit vouloir amorcer les travaux
le plus tôt possible une rencontre doit
avoir lieu entre les propriétaires
touchés et Transport Canada vendredi
prochain ici Jean Rennes Radio-Canada
lac mes grands sick
[Musique]